the wuhan lab leak oh yeah
is gonna be the story over the next
couple weeks i think uh
your boy fauci was testifying in front
of congress
and uh about his role in it but
he always said there's no way that this
is a lab leak at all this is uh
it was caused by a bats and these covid
viruses come from bats right and i don't
know about all this [ __ ]
but in the next couple weeks we should
probably have an expert
come on and explain it to you guys
you know someone who really knows the
ins and outs
of all these situations i mean it's
definitely not true
and we're not saying it's factual but
they might have some interesting things
to say
hmm that's all i'll say about that but
um
this is going to be the big story
because it looks like the biden
administration is throwing fouchy under
the bus
they got him on the hot seat and he was
the darling of the democrats before
right yeah so if it comes out because
most of what happened was there are a
few people who worked at the wuhan lab
yeah and they got sick in november had
to be hospitalized
right and then china of course covering
that [ __ ] up yep right
but if it does turn out that
this [ __ ] came from a lab in china and
wuhan specifically
i need my apology though i need my
apology from all the bloggers that call
me racist for calling that [ __ ] the
chinese flu the wuhanic plague
who said i was racist for putting out a
thing blaming china for the virus
if the [ __ ] literally comes from
government-funded labs in china
and they let it leak which was not what
we were doing we were just being
hyperbolic
we were joking around joke it was an
absolute [ __ ] joke but you called me
racist but if we end up being right
in our joke i need an official apology
oh cause you took our joke serious
yeah so now if the serious thing is
accurate
i'm gonna need the apology and i'm gonna
need it to be just as loud as the
criticism you know
do we not need apology for that we lost
a sponsor over that bitch-ass
[ __ ] sponsor
how many i'm gonna need apology from
them and lost wages though
i'm gonna need lost wages yo before i
sue
i'm a sue i'm a suit for i'm a suit what
is that [ __ ]
it slander yeah liable slander
defamation yeah
don't hit him hit him with it get it
doing bro let's get it going
let's get the lawsuit machine going here
i was just thinking i was trying to be
racist
turns out i'm right it turns out i'm
right
yeah every time every time i'm trying to
be racist
turns out i'm right yeah just look at
the numbers you know statistics
just it's just raw numbers i took my
wallet and i put in the other pocket
and it turns out he was trying to steal
my wallet
i was right guys it's called a hunch
but we'll have someone here to describe
what they think is really going on but
if that's true
why is economic sanctions on china so
[ __ ] crazy cause we [ __ ] bro that's
the thing i don't understand it we [ __ ]
yeah
don't get it and everybody doesn't even
acknowledge as possible you don't gotta
go to war with them
but if they're thriving from a pandemic
that leaked from one of their labs
i'm not saying [ __ ] you or whatever i
mean i'm saying it but you can just be
like yo
we just can't [ __ ] with you for a while
you gotta have some kind of punishment
for that because that caused a global
pandemic can we be honest y'all then
they're gonna throw sanctions back on us
there's no way
going broke in the same way we sanction
what we should do
is we should build up
first of all we got to get rid of
democracy in india that was
gonna give you they're working on it
they're working on it don't worry good
they should
get rid of democracy because it can't
get to where we need it to be fast
enough fascinating
because if you had a dictator if you had
like a singaporean type system and i
understand it's very different singapore
is a
barely a [ __ ] city so tiny and you're
talking about
one of the largest countries in the
world in terms of population right
number one
number one okay so it's much different
i'm not saying it's possible but
the democratic process the one of the
good things about it is it grinds slowly
right and the bad thing about it is
because it grinds [ __ ] slowly
so if you had a dictator that could just
organize some [ __ ] in india so that we
could
put all those jobs over there we could
start building these factories we start
executing things that we need to execute
in a timely manner then we take away
some of the power of china
would you would you do the honor i will
i will be the dictator of india i'm in
it i'm in let's go
i will be the dictator what position is
in my cabinet and what am i
you're also in my cabinet yes alex team
china sorry he's probably gonna turn
down well alex is at the chinese pool
party wow
oh sorry i couldn't make it to the cabin
they celebrating wins all right so now
that we're leading india what do we do
um well there's a couple things that we
have to do right we have to
we have to stop the rapes yeah no
first they got to stop is the [ __ ]
spreading on themselves
yeah yeah that's a good point well
that's what the women were doing to stop
the rapes
what do you think that there is you
thought that they were doing that for
fun
about the dudes who are doing it what
what the guys that are they'd be raping
guys out there too bro anybody could get
it
yo friction is friction today
anyways bro make the snake rise bro
that's all they care about bust out the
flute it's time to get
can you yeah
[Laughter]
well yeah so we need to we need to start
that number one what about the farmers
how are you gonna settle that
we gotta settle the farmers yeah that's
we've gotta do that settle it yeah i
mean
i think i have a great solution to
settlements we're gonna go settle on
their land
calm down
everybody chill out um no no but we have
to settle up we have to settle with the
farmers right
and um let them farm bro yeah
let them farm let them slowly honestly i
want them to farm
we're gonna switch the things that they
farm yeah
we got it we got to say again tech no
farming crypto
not crypto oh that's mining that's not
that's mining we're not going to let
them mine
yeah but we have to let them farm things
that we think would be
useful right things that we can use
correct they need to make fleshlights
you give every guy a fleshlight oh i got
one step back
attach a fleshlight to cattle
that's everything they love dude you
have you have a cow
you're not touching the cows you're
touching the flashlight why can't if you
love cows why can't you make them feel
good
yeah how are you that's a real rapist
logic
why can't you make them feel good you
asked the ultimate lovers though the
karma suit that you got kyle in the
clock
the countdown bro but i don't think they
would touch the cow even had fleshlight
they can't disrespect the cowardly
they're gonna grab a woman but they
can't run but
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] got to start dressing up
as cows bro literally give women cow
costumes we just saw the rape john
give women calculus i like that solution
cow costumes are all the way solutions
farmers okay do you do we want the
farmers to stop farming or what do we
want let them farm babies you know what
is the goal how do we help them do they
want to not farm they want a farm they
want a farm and then what's the issue
uh tax or something like that i already
forgot all right wow
[Applause]
he invested five grand into him yeah
that's wild no five grams of cobin
how do you not know what the [ __ ] is
going on this might be pissing me off
right
now you're out of the cabinet bro you're
out you can't you can't lead individuals
you might be out of the cabinet yeah
they want their minimum support pricing
back i remembered that's right
that's what it is he just he just dumped
it pressure
pressure makes diamonds i was like damn
we how we back at farmers actually
let me move on to covert killing
everybody i gotta [ __ ] about farmers
again [ __ ]
[ __ ]
let's give the guys their phone prices
give them their msp that's it
yeah yeah yeah you gotta remember it now
okay okay
if they farm corn that solves it that
they farm corn
yeah okay let's give them some corn
let's give them corn can we give them
corn that's what happened in america
they just all farm corn and everybody's
good now just put corn and everything
cool yeah
corn syrup corn syrup ethanol ethanol
corn syrup they also have
grits on the cob on the cob
is litty cream of that's also dope
uh-huh
canned they will do a lot with corn
start making uh tortilla chips
native american's gotta give us a little
bit of respect for what we did to corn
fritters
oh they got um uh pitas no no that's not
corn what's the other one
tacos next thing's got tacos acorns are
lit
yeah yeah yeah that's not type of corn
indians were messing with little tiny
corns
what's the bread that you break to eat
the food no no none
yeah yeah start switch that to corn so
what's that the corn real time also corn
way healthier for your diet
it is you don't eat corn i'm not healthy
[Laughter]
but i also don't eat none that's one of
your big
i eat a little bit of corn if i have to
eat corn i will but i try to not eat
corn
mm-hmm because that's just horrible for
you don't let them do corn
do you do
uh chemically engineered yeah well i saw
this documentary
your body doesn't even absorb it you
ever eat corn yeah [ __ ] it right out
yeah it's just
i i was corn this weekend it's plastic
food it's not real
no nutrition it's kind of fun to see
your digestive cycle though yeah i'll
sometimes throw some corn in there just
to know when i'm
like how long it takes you to put it
exactly yeah i do i should do yeah just
kind of know like where i'm at
oh two days how do we even get into this
uh because we're
dictating uh no before that we're the
dictators of india china
in order to take over china oh the
fouchy [ __ ] oh yeah yeah so then i think
we got to get our money over there to
india bro i'm talking that man like
europe europe how many indians we got in
europe how many indians we got in
america like we love indians we [ __ ]
with indians bro
that's true you know what i mean there's
never been a stop indian hate ever
even when we did hate y'all we didn't
even mean to yeah
we got it wrong we were too stupid it's
communication different just in this
communication complete miscommunication
yeah true so we love indians bro it's a
good point
we're lovable y'all are the most lovable
people no matter where they go people
love them bro
think about that they're about
swallowing first we are not that's
also what we're doing no we're not about
pakistan
we're absorbing pakistan we're taking
pakistan back yeah we give him we're
giving pakistan back to
pakistan as india country it's not a
country anymore india
way better when it was india if i'm
being honest
yeah y'all fell off over there y'all
fell off
just take them back call them indians yo
i think we gotta take it back i don't i
don't recognize that
that's what i'm saying bro we're taiwan
in them but where's john cena
when you meet him he's gonna be out
there
pakistani hindustan they will dabble
will dabble they will dabble they will
dabble they will dabble pakistani they
will dabble
in the stun i'm sorry
you